الملفات والمسربه من لا تزال تثير ضجه
واسعه وتشغل بال اطراف متعدده تساؤلات
عديده تطرح حول كيفيه تسرب هذه الوثائق في
انتظار الكشف عن نتائج التحقيق والذي قد
يستغرق اسابيع هذا ما اكده مسؤول امريكي
في تصريحات لشبكه سي ان ان حيث قال ان
التحقيق في تسريب الوثائق المسربه قد
يستغرق اشهر وذكرت صحيفه ان تحقيق سيحاول
تحديد نطاق التسريب سيما وان المسؤولين لا
يعرفون حتى الان ما اذا كانت هناك المزيد
من الوثائق المسربه التي لم تنشر بعد
واوضح المسؤول ذاته ان المعلومات السريه
يتم تداولها عبر الاف الموظفين في الفانتا
ونبقى مع مساله تسريب الوثائق منكون فقد
شددت وزاره الدفاع البريطانيه على اهميه
توخل القراء الحذر في التعامل مع
الادعاءات التي من المحتمل ان تنشر
معلومات غير دقيقه حياه التسريبات
لاستخباراتيه الامريكيه واشار متحدث
الدفاع البريطاني على حسابه في تويتر ان
هناك مستوى خطيرا من عدم الدقه في
التسريبات مؤكدا على اهميه الحذر في
التعامل مع المزاعم التي لها قيمه ظاهريه
والتي من المحتمل ان تنشر معلومات مضلله
هذا وكشف موقع اكسسوس الامريكيا مسؤولا
اسرائيليا اكد بان واشنطن تواصلت مع
اسرائيل بعد تسريب وثائق عن دعم المصاب
للاحتجاجات مشيرا الى ان واشنطن نصحت
بلاده بعدم المبالغه في رد الفعل على
تسريب تلك الوثائق السريه هذا وكشف الموقع
بان اداره بايدن حاول الطمانه المسؤولين
الاسرائيليين في الايام الاخيره لان
واشنطن ملتزمه بعلاقتها الامنيه مع
اسرائيل بعد التفاصيل الوارده في مجموعه
من وثائق الفانتاجون السريه والتي من
شانها ان تزعزع العلاقه بين امريكا
واسرائيل لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار
والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات
والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في
قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب
وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات